Hilary death holds hands in New York  City with her beau I reached out to  Jason yes look at him he sounds funny  and he likes to Russia the younger star  apparently really likes guys named Jason  she steps out with fitness trainer Jason  Walsh while shopping in soho on  saturdays a source confirms to ET the  two are dating def kept it casual  rocking jeans and off the shoulder  sweater and beanie later that night the  two went to dinner in tribeca and the 28  year old mama of one changed into a more  high fashion look the only thing more  amazing than those pink thigh high boots  is that Jason Walsh is wearing the exact  same outfit as deaf tinder date also  named Jason from a music video sparks  the two were spotted out again on Sunday  grabbing lunch which Duff posted to her  Instagram story the pair have been seen  together in public before but neither  have commented on the status of their  relationship delft officially divorced  from hockey player mike comrie in  February 2016